startling new numbers from the sources
within Customs and Border Protection
showing just how vulnerable America's
national security has become under the
Biden Administration CBP sources telling
Fox News Griffin uh Griff Jenkins rather
that over 28,000 migrants have evaded
apprehension at the southern border
since the new fiscal year started
October 1st this is just a few weeks
this on top of the more than one and a
half million Goda aways that we know of
already during Biden's presidency
Customs at border patrol sources also
telling Fox News that nearly 2,000
Chinese migrants have been encountered
at the southern border for the first 14
days of the fiscal year many of them
military AED men putting strain on
States across the country joining me
right now with his plans to manage it in
this Sunday morning Futures exclusive is
Virginia governor Glenn yunan Governor
good to see you this morning thanks so
much for being here this
morning yeah good morning Maria and I
just want to let everyone know how uh
proud I am of Republicans coming
together Around Speaker Johnson and
getting things moving it's a critical
time around the world and in our nation
and we need leadership and I'm happy to
see him go to work and what does that
leadership mean for
Virginia well as you know Maria we're in
the we're in the middle of very
important elections I think the most
important elections in the nation and we
have a chance to put on the ballot our
track record of growing jobs and back in
the blue and standing up for parents and
and reinforcing excellence and education
and I think these are foundational to
America's success we're going to have
Virginians come out and and hope
hopefully flip our flip our Senate and
hold our house and this is what's at
stake and so it's great to see
Republicans unified working working
together in order to to advance the
interests of America not only around the
world but at home here in the states and
your comment around the chaos that we're
seeing at the southern border is just
another example of the weakness from Joe
Biden we see weakness in foreign policy
and now we have international chaos we
see weakness at the border and we have
drug chaos National Security chaos chos
and humanitarian chaos and we see
weakness in our economy because he
doesn't understand that we have to have
fiscal responsibility we have to have an
aggressive energy policy that preserves
our advantage as as a domestic full
supplier of everything that we need and
this is working against America in all
aspects and I see it in Virginia as we
see inflation stealing hard-earned
Virginians money we see people worrying
about their next job and yet here we are
fighting against it with with providing
huge tax relief we have tax checks going
out this week to Virginians we've gone
from the bottom of job growth to near
the top of job growth in the country
Common Sense conservative policies work
and I'm so excited to present those to
voters here in the next 10 days so you
think this is one of the most important
elections if not the most important
election for the country when you take a
look at the legislature in Virginia how
can you reverse some of this do you
think that getting the seat in Virginia
could help the Republicans take the
Senate overall
yeah absolutely and and at the at the
heart of this is a state that just 24
months ago was completely controlled by
the Democrats and in 24 short months
we've put Common Sense conservative
policies to work Virginia is soaring and
now Virginians have a chance to not just
give us our house majority back but flip
the Senate and therefore I will no
longer have a group of progressive left
Senators that try to block us at every
turn and we can unleash the full
potential of the Commonwealth further
reducing taxes further backing the blue
further empowering parents and further
working together towards a future for
Virginia that I think reflects on the
future for America I think there's hope
in what we're doing in Virginia right
now all the progressive left is doing is
trying to sell fear and hope beats fear
every day of the week tell me about the
open border and how it's impacted
Virginia because we're talking about 7
million people who have come into this
country on Joe Biden's watch uh the Goda
ways these are just the Goda ways that
we know of there are plenty more that
have uh gotten into this country evaded
apprehension uh what has it meant for
Virginia and what does the Border need
they're talking about sending money to
the Border it's my understanding that
the Border doesn't need money it needs a
policy
change yeah uh let me begin that
Virginia has 8.7 million people so we've
nearly seen the entire state of Virginia
come across the border it's unbelievable
and and this chos that has not only
created a humanitarian crisis is
creating a national security crisis and
a drug crisis and we've seen the cartels
press into all of the states so now
every State's a border state we are
working hard to try to inter interdict
the the the illegal flow of drugs across
the border we have on average five
Virginians a day that die of fentol
overdoses uh this is what's happening at
the border so we have to secure the
Border it is a full policy shift so that
we can stop the flow of illegal drugs
illegal people and really criminals
coming across the border and we see it
every day in the Commonwealth our law
enforcement agencies are working hard in
order to combat this but let me tell you
violent crime is a real challenge
because of gangs and drugs and this all
starts at the border and let me get your
take on the anti-Semitism that we're
seeing now erupt across the country and
particularly on college campuses you've
been so good on education and took a
real leadership role in terms of what
was happening in our schools how would
you assess these protests ongoing at at
our colleges across the country right
now well it all starts with with with
the indaal condemnation of a terrorist
attack on the Jewish people in Israel
and let's be clear this was brutal and
barbaric they invaded Israel and killed
women and children literally in ways
that are almost hard hard to conceive
and therefore while we always want to
protect our constitutional rights I
absolutely condemn what's being chanted
at the at these rallies and I think we
need leadership from our college
campuses the bottom line is I question
what's being taught on these college
campuses if we have students that don't
fully understand the brutality of a
terrorist group Hamas is a terrorist
group and they committed a terrorist act
and they killed women children and we
have to condemn it if we don't we
condone it and there's no fence to sit
on here Israel has the absolute right to
defend itself they must eradicate a
terrorist organization and we have to
stand with them and I think it just
reflects the fact that there is reckless
Reckless speech going on across this
country at this moment and we need to be
unified in our support of Israel
Governor you were also so good in terms
of pushing back on China and you have
been uh very much on alert
uh what do you think is going on with
all of these Chinese uh Nationals coming
into the Country Now by boat into
Florida and and the keys there you can't
just leave China right and just get on a
boat and come to America without getting
approval from the communist government
is is isn't that
right well it all starts with Joe
Biden's weakness when it comes to to
foreign policy and it's creating chaos
around the world and his weakness in
dealing with China has enabled China to
feel very confident about their economic
coercion their military aggression their
extensive surveillance and on top of
that now trying to embed Chinese
Nationals in America so that they can
advance their agenda and this is why we
work so hard in order to ban Tick Tock
and all our state devices to pass
legislation that forbids the Communist
Party of China from acquiring land in
Virginia I mean Maria we're it's
Virginia we have the largest naval base
in the world we have quano we have the
Pentagon we have the entire uh National
Security apparatus in Virginia and we're
going to have to protect them and I
think that we need to have the same
legislation across the entire country
that that forbids the Communist Party of
China from acquiring land agriculture
anything anywhere near any of our
national security installations and this
is critical because they have shown no
hesitation to violate every Norm from
surveillance to planning people in uh in
America and in Virginia gets back to the
Border it gets back to weakness and
international policy it gets back to
weakness of Joe Biden Governor thanks
for your leadership appreciate your time
this morning thank you
sir thank you Mar and all Virginians get
out and vote this week we need your vote
we've got to hold our house and flip our
Senate there you go Virginia governor
Glenn yunan thank you we be right back
hi everyone I'm Brian kilme I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now